>> Sean: TUCKER, GREAT SHOW.
WE BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
MY FULL MONOLOGUE IN JUST A
MOMENT.
BREAKING NEWS RIGHT NOW AS WE
COME ON THE AIR TONIGHT.
JOINING US WITH THIS STORY,
JUDICIAL WATCH PRESIDENT TOM
FENTON.
THIS JUST BREAKING.
WHAT I'VE BEEN ABLE TO READ IS
INCREDIBLE.
LET'S -- WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
>> MORE DOCUMENTS OUT OF THE
OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT SHOWING
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE, GLEN
SIMPSON HAD SPECIAL ACCESS TO A
PERSON CALLED JONATHAN WINER
THAT WAS IN THE KERRY STATE
DEPARTMENT.
HE WAS WORKING WITH A TOP AIDE
AND VICTORIA NEWLAND AND STENY
HOYER.
IT'S ALL ABOUT RUSSIA AND OR THE
GETTING TRUMP.
IT'S INCREDIBLE TO SEE.
WE WORRY ABOUT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND BRUCE OHR AND
PETER STRZOK.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT WAS ALL
HANDS ON DECK IN TERMS OF
TARGETING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY WERE MEETING WITH GLEN
SIMPSON, CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
CLINTON AIDES, SYDNEY BLUMENTHAL
AND OTHER ASSOCIATESES.
THERE WAS MORE THAN ONE DOSSIER
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO THE FBI AND
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
NOT FROM ONLY CHRISTOPHER STEELE
BUT CREATED BY THE STATE
DEPARTMENT ITSELF TARGETING
TRUMP AND THE DOCUMENTS SHOW
THAT JONATHAN WINER WAS IN
CONTACT WITH GLEN SIMPSON IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2016 WHO THEN
IMMEDIATELY CONTACTED WINER DID,
VICTORIA NEWLAND, A TOP AIDE AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
AFTER THE ELECTION, WORKING WITH
STENY HOYER'S GUY ON THE RUSSIA
ISSUE AND CONVEYING INFORMATION.
STEELE WAS VERY CLOSE TO
JONATHAN WINER.
HE WAS HIS CONTACT AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT GOING BACK A NUMBER
OF YEARS.
>> Sean: LET ME ASK YOU.
I GOT A COUPLE OF THESE.
WHEN WINER IS WRITING TO
GINSBERG, CHRISTOPHER WAS A BIG
FRIEND OF MINE.
I SPOKE TO CHRIS.
IT'S COMPLICATED.
AT ANOTHER POINT, ANOTHER
E-MAIL, TO STEELE AND HIS
PARTNER, REQUEST FOR CONTACTS ON
BEHALF OF THE U.S. WORLD BANK,
INTERNATIONAL MONETARY FUND.
CHRIS AND CHRIS ADVICES YOU
BRIEF THE COUNTRY TEAM, IT WOULD
BE BEST IF NOT COME IN FROM OR
THROUGH ANY U.S. OFFICIAL BUT
STRAIGHT ON REQUEST IN LIGHT OF
THE IMPACT ON MONGOLIA AND NEED
TO KNOW.
AS YOU HAVE NOW HAD MORE TIME
WITH THESE THAN ME, WHAT DO YOU
INTERPRET THESE THINGS TO SAY?
>> THE STEELE'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT GOES
BACK A NUMBER OF YEARS.
HE WAS WELL-POSITIONED TO
LAUNDER THE RUSSIA DOSSIER
INFORMATION THROUGH THIS PERSON,
JONATHAN WINER.
WINER ADMITTED THAT HE MOVED
SOME OF THE INFORMATION OVER TO
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
SO STEELE HAS THIS RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT THAT
IS LONGSTANDING, THE OBAMA STATE
DEPARTMENT.
THEN COMES ELECTION TIME.
HIS CONTACT IS HIS VEHICLE TO
LAUNDER THE INFORMATION INTO THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI.
AND INTO WORKING WITH DIRECTLY
THROUGH VICTORIA NEWLAND, IT
LOOKS LIKE, ANOTHER STOP STATE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL AND WINER,
WHO HAS NO BUSINESS OF DOING ANY
OF THIS, THE LIBYA COORDINATOR
ON THE RUSSIA ISSUES WITH STENY
HOYER'S TOP GUY.
THE QUESTION I HAVE HERE, WHEN
YOU TAKE A STEP BACK, WE SEE IN
OTHER DOCUMENTS THE STATE
DEPARTMENT WAS PUSHING
RUSSIA-RELATED MATERIALS TO
FRIENDLY'S IN CONGRESS.
JUST BEFORE THE PRESIDENT'S
INAUGURATION.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESS KNEW WHAT AND WHEN
ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THEY WERE IN ON
IN AS MUCH AS COMEY, STRZOK AND
PAGE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU ONE MORE
QUESTION.
YOU SAY THE DOCUMENTS SHOW
FUSION GPS AND CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR SPY CHRISTOPHER
STEELE HAD A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT UNDER
JOHN KERRY IS EMERGING AS
ANOTHER CENTER IN ALL OF THIS AS
RELATES TO GOING AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND WINER
WRITING AN OP-ED CLAIMING THAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND
BLUMENTHAL APPROACHED HIM WITH
SEPARATE DOSSIERS, LET'S TIE
THIS TOGETHER, IF YOU CAN.
>> THERE WAS MORE THAN ONE
DOSSIER.
YOU HAVE THE STEELE DOSSIER AND
LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE A DOSSIER
CREATED BY JONATHAN WINER AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
USING STEELE AND SYDNEY
BLUMENTHAL, A CLINTON AIDE OR
PAL AND CODY SHEERER WHO GOES
BACK FOR A LONG TIME WITH THE
CLINTON GROUP.
THIS IS JUST INCREDIBLE IN THE
SENSE THAT EVERYONE IS THINKING
IT'S THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE FBI, THAT'S WHERE ALL THE
BAD ACTIVITY WAS TAKING PLACE.
SECRETARY POMPEO NEEDS TO BE
WORKING WITH A.G. BAR AS CLOSELY
AS ANY OTHER AGENCY HAS IN TERMS
OF DECODING THE DEEP STATE
CONSPIRACY AGAINST THEN
CANDIDATE TRUMP AND THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THEY WERE
DESPERATE TO GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT TO THEIR
FRIENDLY DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL
JUST BEFORE TRUMP WAS
INAUGURATED.
IT WASN'T TO HELP PRESIDENT